[MUSIC PLAYING]
IAN CHAKERES: Thank you
for joining us today.
We're really excited
to talk with you
about bringing your Kubernetes
clusters to Google Cloud.
But before we dive in, we
want to introduce ourselves.
My name is Ian Chakeres, and I'm
an engineering manager in GKE.
And our team is
making it possible
for you to manage and monitor
all of your Kubernetes
clusters, whether they're
in the cloud or on-premise.
I've been working with
Kubernetes for several years,
and I've lived through different
tech transitions, for example,
from bare metal to containers
and monoliths to microservices.
And I've seen the velocity
that these modern technologies
provide by allowing you
to concentrate and focus
on your core business.
Matt?
MATTHEW DELIO: My
name is Matthew DeLio.
I'm a product manager on GKE.
I've been on the team for
about 2 and 1/2 years now.
And for the past year,
I've been focused
on providing a fantastic
multicluster experience
for Anthos customers.
I'm excited to be onstage to
talk to you about our latest
offering.
And I'll hand it back to
Ian to get it started.
IAN CHAKERES: All right,
before proceeding, I
do need to reiterate the
safe harbor statement.
We are talking
about many forward
looking products of
varying maturities.
And the products
and the timelines
are subject to change.
Now that I've told you
about the safe harbor,
we can dig into the talk
about bringing your Kubernetes
clusters to Google Cloud.
GKE he is already our
favorite place for Kubernetes.
And I'm sure you've heard
about the announcements related
to Anthos and GKE
On-Prem and how
these are connected to Google.
We understand that
you, our customers,
have chosen Kubernetes to
enable you to move fast.
We understand that
you have to operate
in many different
environments, and we want
to meet you wherever you are.
Anthos was built to help
you quickly develop, manage,
and operate your business.
And today, we're
excited to talk about
connecting all your
Kubernetes clusters,
no matter where they are.
Matt?
MATTHEW DELIO: Thanks, Ian.
So we're going to
start out today
by exploring the problem
space a bit more.
We're going to see what
challenges you're facing
and show how Anthos can help
address those challenges.
The second thing, Ian will
give a technology deep dive,
so you can learn a little
bit more about the product.
We'll finally end
with some demos,
so you can have more concrete
view of what we're doing.
To get started, let's
focus on the first section
then, which is the
problem statements.
So when we talk to you, we often
hear a very similar message.
In order to be successful, your
business and IT organization
needs to be able to adapt
to rapid changes in consumer
demand, and you also have
to create competitive edge.
We know you need to
do this simultaneously
in multiple clouds and
on-premises while also
reducing risk and cost.
This is a tough challenge,
but it's not impossible.
Microservices and
containers can help
make your developers and
operators more productive,
and Kubernetes in
combination with an Anthos
can help you run
more efficiently
in these multiple environments.
First, let's dive in to find out
how microservice can help you
achieve better velocity.
In the VM and bare
metal era, applications
were built as monoliths.
They had very little
component modularity,
and it was very difficult to
actually build and release.
So this totally made sense
given the tools and solutions
that were available.
However, it really wasn't the
best way to build and release
software services.
You know, monoliths
tend to be built
and qualified as one unit.
And so a bug in one
part of the code
can hold up an entire release.
And as a result, teams tend
to move more slowly when
they're building monoliths.
Microservices help
fix this issue.
They allow you to break apart
your services to introduce
much more modularity.
Teams can then operate
independently for one another,
releasing their pieces
at their own pace.
And they really only need
to focus on making sure
that their APIs remain stable.
However, to be effective,
microservices also
require different packaging
and runtime mechanism, hence
containers.
With containers, you can
put all your microservices
and all their dependencies
into small immutable images.
These allow you to
reuse the same binaries
when developing, testing, and
productionizing your workloads.
This makes it easier and
faster to develop and debug.
And as a result,
developers and operators
can focus more on development
instead of managing
and patching infrastructure.
We've gone over
microservices containers.
And this finally brings
us to Kubernetes.
Kubernetes does a lot of things
to help running containers
and microservices efficient.
Today, we'll focus on one key
aspect needed to move quickly
in multiple environments.
And Kubernetes provides an
abstraction for the underlying
infrastructure.
This is super important.
With Kubernetes, you can
learn one technology,
one set of APIs, and apply it
anywhere that Kubernetes runs.
You can develop
common tooling that
works across all environments,
and this will really
give you the ability to run
your applications efficiently,
in cloud, and on-premises.
Next we'll spend a
few minutes discussing
why you'd want to run
in multiple environments
in the first place.
This mostly falls
in four use cases--
modernizing in place,
offering choice for both
the organization
and the developers
within your organization,
tackling local compute needs,
and finally, technical needs.
The first use case,
modernizing in place,
usually has two facets to it.
The first one is data gravity.
Your data tends to be collected
and placed in one location
or in a few locations, and it's
very costly and time consuming
to move it around to
wherever your compute happens
to be at the time.
And also legacy services
play into this as well like,
for example, mainframes and
database and other services it
really just cannot
easily be moved to cloud.
They're sort of just
stuck where they are,
and you have to live with them.
But you'd still like to
adopt modern development
and operating practices around
those pieces that cannot move
to cloud.
And you'd like to
use the same tooling
in cloud and on-premises.
And so you turn to Kubernetes
to do exactly this.
Now you can modernize your
applications at your own pace
and move to cloud if
or when it makes sense.
The second use case we
find often is choice.
And like I said,
it has two facets.
One is developer choice.
You tell us all the
time that each cloud
has its own set of managed
services that are really
aren't found anywhere else.
The example of this is BigQuery.
It's only available
in GCP, and some teams
within your organization
might really
want to use this service.
But there might be another team
and another party organization
or even on the same team that
wants to use another cloud
provider's product.
And so it's really important
to give your teams a choice,
so they can choose
the tools that
are most suited for the project
that they're working on.
Another one you've told us
is really important to you
is avoiding vendor lock in.
You want to ensure that you're
not tied to any single cloud
provider.
And then that
means that you have
to choose the software stack
that allows your applications
to be portable.
The third main use case
is local compute needs,
and this often comes up in
kind of industry verticals.
So we've seen it in
industrial and retail for one.
In industrial, it tends to
be manufacturing, warehouse
automation, natural resource
exploration, and many others
that I haven't listed
here where it's
critical to provide compute near
to where it's being consumed.
In the retail side, it's also
somewhat of a similar need.
In brick and mortar
stores, you need
to have local compute for
enhancing customer experience
use cases.
Examples of this are digital
signage, point of sale systems,
credit card processing, and
other emerging use cases,
again that I have
not listed here.
Here it's also critical
to provide compute
near where it's being consumed.
Sometimes we see it
for availability,
but there's also many
other reasons as well.
It's a bit different from
the industrial use case
because there's
likely more locations.
It's brick and mortar, so
there's lots of retail stores
potentially.
And each location likely
has a smaller footprint.
Hardware looks a bit
less like what you'd
find in a traditional center.
It's usually lighter weight,
and remote management
in the retail environment
is super important
because your IT org
isn't often nearby.
This brings us to the
fourth use case, which
is around technical needs.
So you probably leverage
several environments
because you need to meet some
sort of technical or business
need for your
services that you're
offering to your own customers.
To do that, you need to
run multiple environments
to provide low latency roundtrip
times for your services
potentially, or maybe you have
a high bandwidth application
that really needs to
be very close to where
the data is being consumed.
Or maybe you have to provide
resilience against outages
either in your clusters
or whatever environment is
or the entire cloud.
OK, so we went over how
microservices, containers,
and Kubernetes can
help improve velocity.
We saw the reasons why you'd
want to run workloads anywhere.
But how do you actually work
effectively and efficiently
in all of these environments?
And that's why we built Anthos.
At a high level,
it's a software stack
that uses Kubernetes as a
foundation with services
built on top of it.
This makes managing hybrid and
multi-cloud environments easy.
At its core, Anthos is made up
with three main components--
a set of cloud services
provided by Google,
a marketplace of third-party
solutions, and a control plane
for managing these
various environments.
On the compute side,
which is the part
at the bottom of the slide here,
we've got three environments.
This is examples.
We've got GCP, on-prem, and
then other cloud providers.
And the idea behind
this is this stack
allows you to write once,
deploy in any cloud,
achieve developer and
operator consistency
across environments, increase
workload mobility, modernize
your applications in place
or wherever they need
to be modernized, and accelerate
developer velocity as a whole.
For this talk, we're going
to focus on this box we've
got here in red.
It's really the connection
between the clusters running
in each one of these
environments, specifically
the Kubernetes clusters.
And we're going to focus
on observing and managing
workloads across those clusters.
If you're an existing Anthos
customer using GK On-Prem,
you're actually familiar
with this technology already.
It's what we're using to
connect GKE on-prem clusters
to the cloud.
What we're announcing today
is an alpha feature for Anthos
that allows you to view and
manipulate your Kubernetes
workloads using the
GCP cloud console,
and it's any Kubernetes cluster.
I'll now hand it
over to Ian, who
will go through some of the
technology we've developed.
IAN CHAKERES: Thanks, Matt.
Thanks for making
that announcement,
and I'm going to tell you
a bit about the technology
behind this.
And then we're going
to be able to get
to a bunch of different demos.
So I'm going to start by
talking about the Cloud Console
and then talk about the
technology that actually
connects clusters to Google.
The Google Cloud
Console is a single pane
of glass for all
your GKE clusters,
and we're extending it to
support Kubernetes clusters
anywhere.
In GKE On-Prem,
all these clusters
show up right alongside your
existing GKE On Cloud clusters.
The single pane of
glass allows you
to manage and monitor your
workloads in the same way
no matter where they are.
You can dig into each of the
different clusters and cluster
resources, for example,
the version of Kubernetes
and the nodes that make up
that particular cluster.
You can view and inspect
the different workloads,
for example what is
deployed within each
of the different clusters, the
version of the different pods
and containers, as
well as the status
and the health of the
different Kubernetes objects.
The GKE UI also provides
additional context
and surfaces
relevant information.
For example, if you're
debugging and you have trouble
scheduling workloads
or workloads
are pending or container
images that can't be pulled--
this information is brought
to the forefront by the UI.
If you have sufficient
permissions,
you can also manipulate
resources directly
from the UI, for example,
scaling up a deployment,
when you expect to
have more traffic
or you need higher redundancy.
The Cloud console provides this
consistent UI for your admins
and your developers across
clouds and across clusters.
So now that I've told
you about the UI,
I'm going to tell
you about connecting
your clusters to Google.
To register your
clusters with Google,
you install an agent inside
your Kubernetes cluster.
When you're using GKE
On-Prem, this registration
occurs automatically when
you create the cluster.
If we look at the image on
the right, in the bottom half,
this is actually
your infrastructure
with your Kubernetes clusters
with Kubernetes API servers
in them.
The top half, this is Google.
So you run this agent
within your cluster,
and it reaches out to Google.
The cluster and the
API server do not
need to have any public IPs
or be publicly accessible,
so you can keep your
clusters private.
The agent itself can traverse
VPNs, NATs, firewalls,
and proxies.
And if for any reason the
agent gets disconnected,
it will periodically attempt
to reconnect to Google.
So now that I've told you
about connecting to Google,
I'm going to tell you about how
we secure those communications.
So the connection between
the agent and Google
is authenticated and authorized
using a GCP service account.
Looking at the
diagram on the right,
within the cluster
near the agent,
you have that key and
the little cloud icon.
This actually is the credentials
for a service account,
and it unlocks the
service on the Google
side, the lock above it.
The service account is bound
with specific permissions
that allow the agent to connect
to your project at Google.
After this connection
is established,
it is secured using TLS and SSL.
TLS provides the integrity
and the encryption
of all the communications
between the agent that
is running in your
cluster and Google.
This service also supports
advanced security features,
like VPC Service Controls
via cloud interconnects, that
will allow you to restrict
from where your agents connect
to Google.
And now that we've got
a cluster connected,
we can talk about logging in.
So when you visit a Cluster
in the Cloud Console,
you'll be prompted to
log into those clusters.
Each user logs into a cluster
individually because the login
is specific to that user.
So similar to the prior
diagram, we have a key,
and that is actually at a
laptop at the Cloud Console.
And that is a Kubernetes
credentials for the cluster.
It unlocks capabilities
on the API server
within the cluster to
which it is connected.
So when you log in, you
are logging in as you,
and the permissions that
you have within that cluster
are based upon your Role-Based
Access Controls, or RBAC,
and the key is your credentials.
So when you log in,
you are actually
interacting with
the cluster, and you
are authenticated as you
and you are authorized
to perform different actions
as you on the cluster itself.
One of the benefits
of this mode is
that all of the
interactions that you
have with the
Kubernetes API server
are audit logged at that
Kubernetes API server.
The other thing is
that administrators
can control what permissions
you are authorized to do.
The Cloud Console supports
multiple different ways
to log into clusters,
for example, using
basic authentication, like a
username and password, as well
as Kubernetes service
account tokens.
We'll also be offering OIDC
and supporting Active Directory
for login soon.
Administrators can use
our RBAC permissions
to scope what users can perform.
At a minimum to
log in, users are
required to have a view and
node reader permissions,
and this is simply so
you can see anything
about the cluster and the
basics of that cluster.
If you are granted higher
permissions, you can see more
and you can do more.
For example, if you're granted
cluster admin permissions,
you can view and manipulate
most of the resources
within the Kubernetes cluster.
And now that I've told
you about securely logging
into your clusters and
interacting with them,
I'm sure you've got
some other questions.
So the first
question is probably
going to be can I connect
my Kubernetes clusters?
So there are a few
things that you'll
need before you can connect
your clusters to Google.
One, you'll need to contact
your sales representative
to get involved in the alpha.
On the other hand, if you are an
Anthos or GKE On-Prem customer,
you'll already be using
these capabilities.
You will need to have a Google
account so that you can log in.
You will also need your clusters
to have connectivity back
to Google so that the agents
can form the connection.
Once your cluster
is connected, you'll
need credentials to
log into that cluster
to be able to interact with it.
You can connect clusters with a
variety of different Kubernetes
versions.
Presently we support Kubernetes
110, 111, 112, and 113.
These are the same
versions of Kubernetes
that are supported on
GKE, and the Cloud Console
supports these.
Now you may be wondering
what types of clusters can
I connect.
You can connect GKE clusters
from other projects.
Your GKE On-Prem clusters
are automatically connected,
and we've connected a wide
variety of different clusters
running both on cloud and
on-premise, for example,
on AWS as your Kubernetes
Engine and even OpenShift.
And now that I've told you about
the different types of clusters
that you can connect, I'm
going to hand it back to Matt.
MATTHEW DELIO: All
right, thanks, Ian.
So we've got three
demos for you today.
I'm going to do the first demo,
and I'll hand it over to Ian
to do the second.
And I'll come back
for the third demo.
The first demo we're
going to do is connecting
a cluster and logging into it.
So we're going to show
you how you would actually
go about deploying the connect
agent, registering the cluster,
and then logging
into the cluster.
We'll also do a brief
tour both beginning
at the end on what
you get with the UI,
and then Ian will spend a
lot more time on the UI piece
again.
So if you wouldn't mind,
can you switch us over
to the demo screen?
Thank you.
So here's my Cloud Console.
I went in.
This is the Kubernetes Engine
page that you normally get.
And here I've got three
clusters already here.
If you look at them
a little carefully,
you'll see that they're
actually not normal.
So I've got an AKS cluster here.
This is an AKS cluster
running on Azure.
This is a GKE cluster,
regular GKE cluster.
And I've also got a
GKE On-Prem cluster
that I set up in San Jose.
So the reason it's not
normal is this is usually
filled with GKE clusters.
Now I've got, like
I said today, we're
announcing that you can
register these other clusters.
And you can see all three
of these in one spot.
So if we click in on
the GKE On-Prem cluster,
you'll see that I can get
some very basic information
about it.
I can find out what version
of Kubernetes is running.
This one happens
to be running 111.
I can see the number of
nodes and the total number
of cores in memory.
If I want to dig
down even further,
I can see what storage has
been provisioned to it,
so I can see what PVC's there.
I can see the provider of the
PVC, so it's using vSphere,
and I can also see
the storage classes
that exist inside this cluster.
If I click on Nodes, I can
see even more information.
It'll break down
those three nodes
and tell me information about
the amount of memory, CPU,
and storage that's available.
And I can click on
any one of these nodes
and actually see the running
workloads inside them.
So as you can see,
I'm running Prometheus
and a few other things
on this cluster.
I can also see some
high level summaries
around the different
resources I'm
using as well as conditions,
like disk pressure, memory
pressure, and the other types
of issues that we're seeing.
If I go back to the
cluster list page,
I had to zoom in for
the purposes of the demo
just so you could see
everything on the screen.
But there's a new button here
that says Register Cluster.
And if I were to
click on that, you'll
get brought to the screen here,
which it's a multi-step process
to help get
installed, but you'll
see how quick the steps are.
So the first step is just to
configure the connect agent--
the thing that we're going to
install inside the cluster.
It turns out I've got a
cluster already ready.
It's a kops cluster
that I built on AWS.
And so I'm going
to go to name it.
I'll call kops on AWS.
And the next thing we need
is the service account key.
And as Ian mentioned, we need
to have a service account
so that we can authenticate the
connect agent that's running
in your cluster back to Google.
So when it connects,
it'll actually
show up with a Google
identity that recognizes,
and it'll authorizes it to work.
To do that, let's switch over
so you can see on my screen here
I've got two text files.
And we'll get to the first
one actually in a minute.
But the second one here--
the GCP service account--
is that service account.
So I'm going to copy
that into my paste buff,
and then we'll go ahead
and paste that in here.
If we had an egress proxy,
we can also configure that,
but we don't in
this environment.
So I'll just hit Continue.
I'm presented with
a thing to download.
So I'll go ahead and
download this manifest file.
And we'll go ahead
and copy the command
that we're going to run.
When we hit Enter, it'll
actually go and install
the manifest.
The agent will manifest
inside the cluster.
You'll see it creates
a namespace for it
itself, a few service accounts,
and roll bindings, as well as
a secret.
So that GCP service account ends
up being put into the secret
here.
And finally, there's a
deployment that actually
has the agent that's running.
When it's done
connecting, you'll
see there's a checkbox
on the screen.
That means it's
connected back to Google.
It's authenticated itself.
We'll hit continue.
Here we're going to
set some basic metadata
about the cluster.
So when I created this, I
created it in US-West-1A
on Amazon, and providers is AWS.
We can also set
some other metadata
that we might want to use later
for maybe a CI/CD pipeline that
can actually look at
the key value pairs
that we set on the cluster.
So let's call this one
environment production,
and we click Register.
And we're going to be brought
back to the cluster list page,
and you'll see that we
have our four clusters now.
The last one is the new
cluster we just registered.
And you'll see that
also we need to log in.
So anybody who goes to their
Cloud Console right now
will get a similar view.
And they would also
have to log in.
So when I log in, I'm going
to log in as just myself.
And it turns out that I am
the admin for this cluster.
So I'm going to copy the
admin token into there,
and then we'll go ahead and
just paste that right in here
and click Login.
As soon as I'm done
logging in, I'm
again brought back
to the page, and you
can see that now I have more
information about the cluster.
If we wanted to, we could go
in, and we could click on this
and do the same kind of
exercise we just did.
But yeah, that's it
for the first demo.
If we go back two
slides real quick--
so as you saw, we were able
to deploy the connect agent,
register the cluster,
and then log into it,
and then we were able
to browse around in UI.
I'll now hand it
over to Ian, who
will do the next set of things.
IAN CHAKERES: Thanks, Matt.
Demo gods are happy.
MATTHEW DELIO: Yes, yes.
IAN CHAKERES: All
right, so Matt talked
about connecting a cluster.
I'm actually going to talk about
monitoring, generally debugging
some problems, and
performing some updates.
So the first thing I'm going
to do is look at the workloads
and actually look at the
contextual and actual
information that
surfaced through the UI.
There is going to be a problem.
And so we're going to kind
of dig into that problem
and see how we can
reconcile that problem
or resolve that problem.
We'll make some changes and
actually solve the problem.
Then we're going to
scale up a deployment.
So we know that we're going
to need some redundancy,
or we're expecting
some more traffic.
So we'll go ahead and we'll
scale up an application.
And then finally, we've got a
new version of our software--
that same software
we've scaled up--
and now we're going
to roll out an update.
And we're going to roll out
that update incrementally using
a rolling update that
Kubernetes provides.
Please switch over
to the demo laptop.
OK, so Matt was in
the cluster page,
and now I'm going to go
over to the workloads page.
MATTHEW DELIO: I think it's
the Wi-Fi or the network
connection.
It should come up in a second.
There it goes.
IAN CHAKERES: All right, great.
So in the workloads page, we see
a bunch of different Kubernetes
objects.
We get their names.
We get green checkboxes
for the status,
and then we also get the type
and the pods, the namespace
and the cluster that
they're running in.
And we can see
the connect agents
from each of the
different clusters.
And we can actually
see there's something
going on here with this one.
We don't get that checkbox,
so I'm going to go ahead.
And I'm going to click into
that to see what's going on.
All right, so we
can see right away
that there is an error here.
But before we dive
into the error
and really troubleshoot
it, I do want
to look at the
page a little bit.
So again, we have
information about the cluster
with the namespace.
We have labels that we've set.
We can see the replicas here.
And one unavailable,
zero available-- that
doesn't look quite right.
We have the deployment
information, the name,
and the status.
We can see that big
red explanation point
and information about
the container image
that is contained
within this deployment.
And actually, I'm going
to go ahead-- we'll
click in here on Show Details.
So what you can see is we
have an application here
it's from Kelsey.
And there has been a
typo by the developer
in terms of what version
they should deploy.
So it's pretty clear to me.
I think we can debug in
terms of what we need
to do to resolve this problem.
So actually, I'm going to
click over into the YAML.
And here you can
see the deployment,
and you can see all of that
information in the YAML
manifest--
both in terms of the
metadata and the spec
and even the status down here.
And we can see there here
the image with that typo.
So let's go ahead-- we're going
to go ahead and click Edit.
And now we can actually
go in and directly edit
this particular image
and application,
and I'll scroll to the bottom.
And I'm going to hit Save.
Now, what's happening is
that the UI is actually
deploying the manifest
with the updated image tag.
And you can see that it's
saying that the pods are
pending as it's making
that particular change.
We'll just refresh.
MATTHEW DELIO: This
wasn't happening earlier,
I promise you.
IAN CHAKERES: So now, we can
see we've got the green checkbox
on hello.
And also we can see down
here the image tag version.
And we also see the number of
replicas is one is available
and we can also actually look
at the different pods that
are being managed
by this deployment.
So let's just click in
on that particular pod.
We can see even more
information and again
look into the
different parts of it.
And let's go ahead.
We'll look in on the logs
on this particular pod.
And so we got what
we wanted here.
We see that the
server started up,
the health service, as
well as the HTTP service
that is supporting it.
So this looks great.
Now we have debugged
our problem.
We've rolled out a change
to the application.
We've got a green checkbox.
But now we know we
only have one of these.
So let's go ahead
and scale this up,
so we get three replicas of
this particular workload.
So we're going to go to
the Actions tab here.
And we're going to hit Scale.
And so instead of
one, we're just
going to change this to three.
And when I click
this button, it's
going to declare I want three.
And what we expect
Kubernetes is to do
is to actually spin up two
more pods like the first one.
And so what we see immediately
is that we now want three.
We only have one.
Two are not yet up,
so let's hit Refresh.
And let's see now
we have the three.
And we have the green
checkbox on the status.
We have three updated, three
ready, three available.
All of them are version
1.0, and we can actually
click into those
different pods again.
And if we want to look at
the logs of a different pod,
we can see we see
those same status
messages that are indicating
that everything is healthy.
So this is great.
Now our application has
three replicas running,
so we can tolerate an error that
would take down one of them.
But now our developers
have a new version.
So now it's time we want
to roll out a new change.
So I'm going to go back
to the Actions tab,
and I'm going to click
on Rolling Update.
I've set the min seconds
ready here to 10.
This is just to
kind of slow things
down, so we can talk through it.
And I'm going to go ahead
and update the image
tag to version 2.0.
And so when I click Update,
what's going to happen
is it's going to
declare that I now
want three of the pods
running with version 2.0.
And we'll see actually that it's
going to bring up a new version
2.0 pod, and then it's going
to shut down a 1.0 pod.
And then it's going to bring
up another 2.0 and shut down.
And so eventually, we'll
have three of the 2.0 pods
and zero of the
1.0 pods, but it's
going to roll those updates.
So actually, we can see here.
We had those three running.
We have two creating
of the new version.
And again, up here
we see two and two
as it's starting to
shut down one of those.
Let's hit Refresh and
see the next state.
So we still have some pending.
We actually have
three of the new ones
and one still shutting
down it looks like.
All right, so now we've got
the green checkbox again.
We have version 2.0.
We have three of
them running, and we
can if we wanted to go and
look at the logs again.
So we have just shown
troubleshooting and debugging
in the UI.
Then we actually
made some changes
to resolve the problems.
Then we scaled it up, and
then we rolled out an update.
So can we switch
back to the slides?
I'm going to hand it back
to Matt for the third demo.
MATTHEW DELIO: Sure,
thank you, Ian.
All right, so the last thing
we're going to show you today
is how you can
deploy an application
from the marketplace to any one
of these connected clusters.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is we're going to
quickly choose a cluster.
Then we'll have an application
that we choose and configure,
and then we'll just go
ahead and deploy it.
And I'll show you it's
actually quite easy and quick
to get started with this.
So if we can switch back to
the demo, that'd be great.
Can we switch to the computer?
Thank you.
All right, so the first
thing you'll notice
is, if we look at the
Kubernetes Engine tab,
there's a Marketplace button.
I think this actually shows up
in pretty much any page now.
But if you click on
Marketplace, you'll
see that there's a whole bunch
of Kubernetes app solutions.
One of the ones that I'm
just going to show today
is just a basic Nginx instance.
So if we search
for Nginx, you'll
see that we get a
list of solutions.
If we narrow it down to
just Kubernetes apps,
we're presented
with this result.
If we click on that, we'll get
a little bit more information
about the solution.
You can read more about
pricing, and this one
happens to be free.
You can learn more about
click to deploy containers
and the applications themselves.
Now we want to deploy this one,
so let's go and hit Configure.
And it'll bring
us to a new screen
where I've got a
lot of information
here that will allow
me to configure it.
So I can select amongst
any of those four clusters.
Since I registered that
kops cluster running AWS,
let's go ahead and
deploy it there.
I can choose what
namespace to deploy it to
as well as a number of replicas.
Let's just choose one to
make it a little bit faster.
If I hit Deploy now,
it will actually
use that connection we've
created between your cluster
and Google.
And it will use the credentials
that I just logged in with
to actually deploy
this application.
This turns out it will take
a few minutes to deploy.
But if we go over to
the Application screen,
you'll see that I
actually previously
deployed a WordPress instance
on that same kops native AWS
cluster.
If I go to the
Services tab, you can
see that we've actually
exposed the Nginx ingress that
comes with the AWS cluster.
And if I click on
this, it'll actually
bring me to the running
instance of that WordPress app.
And so what we've done is we've
integrated with the information
that we get out
of the Kubernetes
objects-- actually show
you the end points running
in other clouds as well.
So the really cool part about
this, just to summarize--
if we go back to the
slides for a second--
is that we were able
to, with a few clicks,
actually deploy an application
from the marketplace.
You saw that demo took less
than two minutes, I think.
And we actually got something
that's up and running,
which is pretty awesome.
And so just to
summarize, today, we
discussed how agility and
velocity along with running
anywhere is top of mind.
We briefly discussed how
Anthos is uniquely positioned
to help you meet your
goals, and we showed you
a feature of Anthos that
helps you get visibility
into your workloads that
are running anywhere.
With it, you can quickly and
easily connect clusters of GCP,
interact with and debug
workloads through the UI,
and even deploy applications
to connected customers
with just a few clicks.
We also mentioned that
connecting any Kubernetes
clusters has just entered alpha.
And if you'd like to learn more
or participate in this alpha,
please contact your
sales representative
to express interest.
[MUSIC PLAYING]